listen I really want to start with a
sincere congratulations on this series
um uh but I'm going to start with you
Kurt uh you have not done anything on
television a television series I believe
since 76 with the quest that's right so
I want to know what was it about this
that said oh I'm I'm doing this actually
it's interesting at the last thing I did
uh in television I think was 79 it was
Elvis and uh you guys haven't seen that
I'm sure it's a long time ago before any
of you were born um but uh I remember
pulling the script out John Carpenter
once said to me he said what was the
moment you kind of said you know I said
I pulled it out and it said Elvis okay
this is this is
interesting and when we were um notified
about this it was uh okay well what is
it well it's in the world it's
Godzilla and when you do that it's a
double-edged sword it's like
okay but for people like us it's like
whoa wait what
Godzilla Godzilla Godzilla yes the
Godzilla so it was that and and honestly
uh interested from that and and then the
opportunity to maybe do something that
I'd never seen um which was uh U known
actors uh father and son playing the
same
person what is it like to do a show with
your dad playing the same character and
you're going to have no scenes with
them um it was it was a Challen it was a
really fun challenge to try and meet
because um you can't hit the nail on the
head with certain things and go we're
going to do this we're going to raise
our left eyebrow just like this right
like you're not you're not going to do
that but but what what we all wanted to
make sure was that you know I've said
this like a thousand times now you go on
these things and you feel like a broken
record but it's true that like as long
as the architecture of the character was
in a place where you knew where you were
going at the end of the show that was
was going to inform who he was and who
who he where Lee who Lee became then
like you could just play the reality of
the scene which is something that we
both I think stand by as ways of of
being as as actors and just play the
scene and it will come across as the
same person because well we do have the
same genetics there's enough there that
enough there you don't need to work too
hard at it um but there were some really
cool things that everybody came up with
like uh some there's some face blending
things and interesting things that
you'll see throughout the show that I
think were really well well placed and
planned and and uh you know helped
helped sell that well we we understood
that that the one character that was
going to connect the times was Lee Shaw
so you had to connect him and you could
never make the mistake of becoming
father and son right and I think we you
know we looked out for that I'm curious
I saw in episode two I want to say that
your birthday on the show is was uh
24 uh in 1924 so I'm just curious is
there something that's going to be you
just really look good for the age or is
it one of these things where it's going
to get into how you are still so active
and spry at that age do the
line question the line yeah no that's
not a spoiler is it yeah it is a it is a
plot point at one point it is a plot
point but at one point one of one of the
characters says don't let this go to
your head but you look really good for
90s
something uh so I want to first of all I
want to give a huge thank you to Apple
TV for partnering up to do the screening
tonight but
I but I also want to give a shout out to
Apple TV for putting on such incredible
sci-fi between s uh Silo For All Mankind
foundation and now this uh for you guys
can you sort of talk about Apple as a
partner in this because they really are
throwing great resources
and making it so something like this
just could be shown on a movie screen
and it looks like it belongs on a movie
screen uh yeah I mean look I I can't
really speak to those other shows it was
our relationship with apple was it
wasn't about it being a science fiction
show it was really just about we have to
make the absolute best version of this
that we possibly can and it has to look
great it has to tell the best story it
has to be about these characters it has
to be driven by their journey and their
story who they are and there's a you
know there's a a a bar that they set you
know that is sometimes intimidatingly
High you know and and there was never
any time where we felt well okay well
this is good enough we're not going to
worry about it this can slide through it
was like no everything from the casting
obviously to to the script work to the
cinematography the whole thing was like
it's just got to be great and it's got
to stand side side by side with the
feature films that our partners the
legendary make right this there's
there's monsterverse movies that we all
know and love and if this looked like
the wait there are oh yeah yeah yeah
they're great you should check them out
uh uh but you it like it's got to stand
side by side by that stuff so when those
moments happen when those big monster
moments happen it's got to be of that
part and and and and a big part of it
was too you know you don't know what
you're going to get a lot of times you
do a movie and you do not know what
you're going to get unless you have a
good filmmaker and like it needs a good
filmmaker you don't have it you can be
like the best actor in the world and
then you see a shitty movie that happens
all the time and so when when we uh my
dad and I were like well who's going to
do the first one and they were like well
Matt shackman is going to do the first
one it made yeah yeah it it made such a
huge difference because you knew you
knew that it was going to be that it was
going to be done in a way that was going
to meet the needs of what Godzilla
needed to be like that gave you
confidence in the ability you and our
ability to to to act the character and
certain ways because he knew it was
going to be in good hands it's very
important and Matt you know obviously
was amazing and did an incredible job so
that was huge thank you for saying that
can I also just acknowledge two parts of
this incredible film making team who are
here today which is Nona Kodi who edited
both one and two and Jess
Hall and and Jess Hall who's the
cinematographer for episodes one and two
as well so they're both here
[Applause]
tonight
what did you guys see one and
two okay I'm pretty objective about this
I've done it for a long time and I'm
very careful it's like a doctor being uh
you know lowballing
it uh this is a a real slow
burn uh and I mean that seriously it it
it this does something that uh is very
hard to achieve it's really wonderful to
be a part of when when when that
achievement is made it gets better and
better and better and better and better
and better and better like that it it
this this is a this this it's going to
be interesting to see how people respond
week to week to week I I would have to
binge this myself uh because there's
you're going back in time and you're
finding out about characters the
Mysteries become doubled and tripled and
and they're always dropping Easter eggs
everywhere but these guys did something
that was
virtually uh next to Impossible when
you're doing a movie you get you're
doing an hour and 45 minutes two
hours uh it take three months to do it
but since 1979 since that
television last time I did tele a show
that was on television I've never worked
on a show that I didn't know the very
last line of the movie because I reverse
engineer
everything I I don't know how you can do
it without that
we're we're starting in shooting in one
and two we don't even know what six and
seven are going to be and these guys are
working on that and they're trying to
build something while the actors are
trying to completely commit to something
that they never want to make any
violations to if you tell the audience
something in four that you completely
violate in six I'm out and I'm I'm
hardgore on that right I'm no fun in
that room so they were having to deal
with
us at the same time they were dealing
with things they weren't even I don't
know what we're going to do there right
and they couldn't give answers they
couldn't they didn't know they're
working to be able to get that within
that
framework to get that M that movie these
are five movies back to back to back if
you consider this a two-hour movie a
two-hour movie a two-hour movie and Matt
shackman did two hours and H Romi and
Mary and Julie
and uh Andy and Andy great I mean they
all did fantastic jobs but guys to do
five movies back to back to back to back
to
back it's it's suicide yeah so that we I
stick around for three four five six
seven eight nine and 10 that's all I can
say and it it requires a lot of trust I
mean it was and I think for these guys
to come in you know with the careers
that they've had and the the talented
people that they've worked with to look
at us and go well I hope these guys
don't make us look like idiots um we
wouldn't let
you going to happen you know it was for
us to say to have those conversations
about well we're not 100% sure where
it's going yet but you know have have
faith we'll get there we'll get there
together we're going to work together
we're going to figure it out um you know
it was it was a journey you know
absolutely and and mix that in with the
fact that when you're out there shooting
something for four months many people
don't understand you you're when you're
shooting on the set you're not making
the movie you're just putting in a
can for them to make the movie later
that Mo all all all movies are made in
the editing room because you're GNA find
things in there you didn't
know this thing all movies have a life
of their own as you're doing them so
they're also dealing with that it's
impressive job guys wayd to go that
actually lead back at you that leads
team effort that leads me to a question
about I'm fascinated by the editing
process because it where it's where it
all comes together so how did this
actually change in the editing room in
ways you guys weren't expecting it was a
three camera half hour sitcom when we
started but you know it wanted to be
something else and Godzilla has got a
mind of his own you just got to let him
go I mean we played around with
structure a lot when do you cut to the
past when do you cut to the present um
those things changed right um yeah the
first episode didn't end where it ends
now where you see it with them losing
cake and the reactor there was a whole
additional scene after that and the
second episode didn't end the way it
ends now uh it ends now with you guys in
the creature and I think it had ended
with with the reveal of Kurt right IMM
yeah yeah and the um uh that first
episode when we watched it in the cut
and we had a scene that we were going to
shoot that was and we watched the cut
and we saw that moment where she where
she falls and we were like Joe's over
it's like you're you don't come back
you're not coming back from
putting anything on after that and we
spent like several days shooting a bar
fight yeah which now appears in sort of
lyrical flashback in the middle of your
meeting well funny story I'll tell it
cuz was seven of us in the room uh the
the what like the way it started out
like Matt and I were like how do you how
should we like do this introduce the
character and I was like I don't know
like what if I like I was smoking at the
time I quit smoking not anymore good for
you but I was like I was like what what
about like light a cigarette M like yeah
that would be cool and like so like we
started out like light on a cigarette
and then and then like a day later it
was like apple didn't we love the fact
that we like started the character with
you smoking a cigarette so we're going
to have to work around that part see
that's stuff that's stuff that you have
to understand I I played Santa Claus
twice and to find out that Netflix did
now you can't I he a he smokes a pipe
the guy lives with a pipe in his mouth
why you know nope yeah that's that this
is a different world but but all that to
say like just a testament to like how
Matt was able to like get around that
you know like I should have been smarter
and been like this is this is stupid
idea why don't don't don't don't don't
do it uh but again a testament to like
how he was able to nimbly move and it
was that was just a lot of fun that
barfight was blast don't you find guys
that you find in the editing
room the it's the first time
you say God I didn't think that was GNA
have that much power that relationship
or God I thought that was funny it's not
it's not funny at all or whoa whoa whoa
wait roll that back oh my God wait a
minute if you flip and you start I mean
it's it's the Magic Room you can't
believe what you can do in an while you
guys love this world so you can you
can't imagine but you find those things
and and and and that's exciting you go
home at night and what you love about
being in part of the circus right it's
your last chance to tell the story
there's something that happens to when
there's a scene like maybe you love it
on the day you love it in assembly and
then at some point it goes away and you
don't even notice it and you're like
that was but that was the part that was
the thing oh my god I didn't even notice
it was gone you know and suddenly it's
like oh yeah no it took it doesn't eat
it anymore right it's it's it's loaded
down the call was the right calls are
made and and you don't even miss what
you thought you would miss I'm curious
for for myself and for the audience uh
What creatures might what can you tease
about some of the creatures this season
or the
monsters oh there's lots of
them I mean there are ones you know like
Godzilla and others that are familiar
and then there's some new ones which are
really cool like new bugs you met
tonight new dragons you met tonight I
think that was the fun of this for those
of you who love the monsterverse and the
Toho films you'll see creatures that you
know and then you'll also see creatures
that you don't know which is what what's
the name of the the no spoiler because
then they haven't seen it yet what's the
name of the thing that has
all oh the uh on the glacier no no no uh
it's like uh at the towards the
end they're doing the work for me it's
fantastic the boar the the the boar with
all that what's it called the Bramble
boar there you go heads up for the
Bramble
boar that's my favorite that thing's
awesome well yeah I mean obviously
there's Godzilla I mean and he's a
presence he's not in every episode but
he is a presence throughout um but we
had a lot of you know latitude to from
both too and legendary and apple to say
okay thank you uh just let your
imaginations around we want new
creatures we want the classic Pantheon
of monsters we want to see those
characters and Toho does refer to them
as characters not creatures or Monsters
they're like these characters you know
have a history they have a Legacy we
want to see them in the show but also we
want to expand that Pantheon you know
and and meet new ones and create new
ones it was a lot of fun we had a great
visual effects team uh headed by Sean
Conrad and amazing and you know just
helped design new things it was well and
Matt shackman can speak to the opening
sequence in the first episode oh yeah
it's fun to design creatures and we had
a whole different plan for how John
Goodman was going to be attacked and
then we found this really cool rock
formation in Hawaii called Lai Lookout
and when I went down there there were
all these little crabs that appeared
that had been blending in and they were
running for me I thought oh we should
just have a giant crab and so then we
designed that big crab based on what we
found which I think is the fun of a lot
of the monsters in the monsterverse
especially in Skull Island you know they
they mixed the Flora and the fauna they
clearly went and found the creepiest
Critters that exist on the world and
then just made them really big
um and that's that's a lot of fun yeah
one of the things I think add so much to
the series is that it's not all sound
stages you're on location a lot and that
location shooting uh just makes it feel
like it's real and you're there and it's
authentic so can you talk about that
being uh on location filming and how
much that added to the show yeah
for having done both um for an actor
when you're actually looking at the
thing that you're supposed to be looking
at it it it makes quite a diff big
difference um and and now what they can
do is you don't have to be acting to a
tennis ball all the time like it what
was so fun about um doing some of the
stuff that we did with with the um we
were in Hawaii doing uh when the lon
Dragon we were like driving into holes
and stuff but was was so fun is talking
with Matt and going like okay now where
is it coming from and I'm not on a Sound
Stage we actually like diving into a
real hole and you know you're going away
from a you can imagine the a real dragon
behind you and it's not like you know in
a sound stage where you're just like
running on a treadmill and that's not
fun and you know exciting to do so that
it makes a huge difference to me you
guys went to a glacier is it this same
exact glacier no from the thing mean
yeah no um no we were in a different
part we were in Haider Alaska slash
something British Columbia Stewart
British Columbia but um this was an
interesting location
um we were all up there uh it was very
warm and the snow pack had come down
from the Scout it was like there was a
foot less everything and and and I I one
day the first day we're there we taking
helicopters up there and uh I'm I'll get
off and you everybody's getting their
bearings and stuff and about two hours
later I looked over quite a ways away
maybe you know four 500 yards away from
where we were shooting and I see this
guy with a group of other guys and he's
got a long 20 foot pole and he's doing
this but he's not moving
fast they put they put a pylon there
okay so they had to you had to be very
careful where you were going and they
when they when we saw that we said when
they roped some areas off us look at the
guys I said they aren't kidding man do
not go past that rope it was pretty
pretty weird that that that that
location I mean you it was a fantastic
you were out in the middle of nowhere
but you were really in the middle of
nowhere and that was weird you know the
this show was for Apple TV's Global
division we wanted a show that looked
like the world and that meant getting
out into it as much as we could and you
know Hawaii and we were in Tokyo for for
two weeks we lost half a day to a
typhoon that was exciting like oh we
lost half a day to a typhoon it's a good
reason to lose half a day but you know
we wanted it to look everywhere you know
we just found amazing locations all
throughout British Columbia um uh it was
hugely important for the kind of scope
and scale of the show to not be on a
volume on you know chasing that stuff we
did use a drone once for eyeline I
remember that uh out of Cash Creek there
was a drone used so so everyone could
could track it in because there was a a
motion that was that was fun we like how
are we going to make everyone do this
like we've got a drone you couldn't hold
a tennis ball high enough for Godzilla
yeah yeah that's actually genius when it
comes to filming with a monster having
the Drone right there everyone sees it
everyone's looking at the right eyeline
that's actually great it's kind of hard
to imagine some of that stuff when
you're out there because the you know um
some of those takes where Godzilla's
tail is sweeping over youh you know and
you're saying now exactly how big is the
tail and it's and it's in it's really
big I mean from here to way over there
you know he's getting bigger and bigger
here um and they got the wind machines
going and stuff it's fun making movies
you know that's what you feel like I'm
curious when it comes to the thing about
Godzilla and the Monsters is that they
all cost a lot of money to put on screen
so I'm curious in the writing process of
the 10 episodes how much were you like
okay uh it cost X number of dollars to
do this so we need to pick and choose
where we're going to deploy these kinds
of big resources in what episode and
when can you sort of take us through or
talk about
how you decided where and when to deploy
the big VFX well it's it's always a
balancing act I mean we
knew we were felt a little bit serving
two masters with this show we knew it
was the Godzilla show and there's an
expectation particularly working with
legendary in the big movies that the
fans of this universe expect to see
their big monsters but we also didn't
feel like that we could sustain a
television series both on a production
level because as you point out they're
very expensive ensive but also from a
storytelling level I mean we couldn't we
from the very beginning we didn't want
to make a show that was a show about
monsters we had to make a show about
people who inhabit a world with monsters
and so where the monsters appeared was
largely driven by story that we had a
group of characters on a quest pursuing
something looking for their father
trying to solve a mystery and the
Monsters kept getting in the way and
they would appear as as uh Matt fraction
points out at at the most inconvenient
moment for our characters when they're
about to get the thing that's a perfect
time to have a giant set piece happen
right but you know we were you know very
conscious of not letting production
concerns guide the writer room in that
process you know there's a crazy
location and set piece in episode three
and then in episode four we're on a
glacier and we were like we're going to
we're going to build the story we're
going to build the place and then we're
going to figure it out and our
tremendous production team made it
happened you know and uh uh marched us
around the world and across many you
know many trucks vans uh few helicopters
airplanes and but it was all
this oh God like it was had to be like
planning a military Invasion like just
the logistics of how can we get we're
trying to figure out how to get a Jeep
to Hawaii oh my God that was a whole
thing about how much money it was like
there was there was it was a whole thing
but there are people who live for the
challenge of like what's that you need a
Jeep in Hawaii on Tuesday and they make
it happen right how much money do you
have yeah yeah uh CarMax no um but it
was it was we had a tremendous
production St aided and abetted Us in
making this giant giant show yeah as
Matt says when we're working in the
writer's room I I I always TR the
writers when you're first thinking about
telling the story just don't write to
the budget it's like write to the story
and we'll figure it out and stuff
sometimes stuff is just way too big and
then you have to come back and you have
to pull it back in and find out okay
what is a producible version that tells
the same thing that you want but I don't
want the team to be con to be thinking
about dollars and cents it's like you
have to think about okay what's the best
story that's serving these characters
and like Matt say I am proud though that
I wrote a pre- outline for an episode
and was told this would be more
expensive than the entire season start
over yeah so so I I took that the
unlimited budget of imagination and I
and I topped it yeah I think it was it
was episode 109 and they said this is
episode 109 110 and and
201 it was fair there was tough but fair
speaking of 201 I am curious when you
are pitching apple on a series like this
they obviously are not thinking one and
done how much are you guys in the Bible
if you will of the show like coming up
they wanted to hear you have a three
season plan or a two season plan or you
know where you ultimately like this to
go like you know what I mean so you're
not uh I'm just curious if that was came
up at all I never like it's such a ol
are you such a such a you know kind of
definitive way but like we love these
characters we love their stories and and
it was clear that there's we could keep
you know there there's more to tell you
know there there we we take this
spectacular Journey uh this season and I
think it it it it it resolves really
wonderfully and emotionally resonantly
and then they're about 10 million other
questions about what's next and I think
it was always understood that we weren't
crafting a limited series but like hey
in success and with good luck we could
keep doing this a long long time because
we've really come to love who these
people are and love throwing giant
monsters in their way right when they're
about to get that thing that makes them
happy so hopefully if that makes you
guys happy and watch early and watch
often well as as as Kurt pointed out
that when you're in the thick of it
trying to figure out what season 1 is
you're not always thinking about what
season two is going to be yeah all I
know is it was our job to try to get him
to season two
so you guys don't want to let Kurt down
do
you it's right
answer absolutely um I'm for all for all
of you guys what when you looked at the
shooting schedule for what you were
involved in what was the day you had
circled in terms of I cannot wait to
film this scene or oh my God I am
dreading fil filming this
scene those days are
gone I don't feel that anymore I don't
get that one you you you don't get no
that's all no if you if you do
that then you're asking for trouble
because I do I have said this to
actors you know at a certain point in
your life you have to say yeah you know
what I've done a thousand of these and
actually I I can be actually I can be
helpful here I always say the like the
last three days you feel that it's like
the end of a season in baseball if
you're in if you're in you know if you
got a chance of making the playoffs yeah
nobody has to say anything to anybody
everybody's you know everybody's going
for it but when we're doing this you you
you don't know what's going to be there
and what's not going to be there you're
only putting stuff in the can for them
to work with I always say this to the
last three days I promise you this
everything we shoot now will be in the
movie otherwise they wouldn't be
shooting it they need this so do not let
down
but you can't you you got to do that the
first day you got the first day you got
to go in there every you got to make
that team every single day I have an
answer when we went into the submarine
on the first the loton on the first
day uh I think that was one of the first
days of shooting and in the
submarine it was like they put on this
Gimbal and it was like cool it was like
exciting you know you're like oh first
day shooting like this is going to be
awesome and uh and the submarine was on
a gimbal That Shook like like if San
Andre fault happened right now that
wasn't Star Trek man that was it was it
was shaking like
crazy and and it looked great and it was
awesome but we were on there all day so
I was like holy that was like you
want to go home and I'm in my bed and
I'm like doing that in my bed
and then and then I say when I got the
call sheet and the next day it was like
interior loton submarine I was like
I don't want to go to work
tomorrow I say that was probably the
only day that I was like oh God okay I
got get well no and but then we did we
we we stopped the shaking came down a
little bit the next day yes I'm sorry
yes I'm sorry but it was great it looked
awesome it's like we I left with the
kind of everyone was like well how was
it I was like it's like fighting a bear
every single day but every day it's a
different
bear I was only felt that on the first
day cuz it wasn't real until we started
you know you guys there the day we saw
the bear were you yes yes yeah yeah yeah
with the Yeah Yeah remember we had to
scare the whole crew we had to scare
away a
bear just that just reminded me of that
this is like a totally this like a
separate story but we're like shooting
the scene with the kid and the rifle in
first episode yeah yeah and like I and
and there's like a starting Mark and
it's kind of like down a little bit
behind a trail like just keep going that
way and like I like go back further
further go back further and and I had
and I had like a gun on him but of
course like so you know some false sense
of security you know so someone turns
around someone says I forgot who it was
I it was beex goes uh goes like she goes
oh my God there's a bear and I turn
around and I'm like holy there's a
bear like right there like right
there and and I I like I know you're
gotos to make yourself big so I was like
go away bear like go away and I
literally reach for my gun and I'm like
yeah hey
Apple this is a big
gun hey apple bad news why I got eaten
by a bear it was like was like how are
we covered for insurance yeah and then
of course like a grip like a tough re
actual tough person comes over with a
air horn and like scares the bear off
like it was really like holy
there's a bear right there it's oh
and then we had the rats we had the
Amorous rats that blew aake in Tokyo oh
yeah yeah that's right we interrupted
some rats honeymoon and uh Anna and kiry
were not
happy wildlife of Plenty in our show
yeah there are eight episodes that
everyone has not seen yet in this
audience uh which of the eight are you
most excited for people to see is there
like one of those eight that you're like
oh I can't wait
it goes for me nine
six8 and then go like 1 two 3 four five
seven that's that's it oh you have it
you I'm gonna say it once so gu that you
miss
it yeah oh yeah yeah it's like yeah it's
good nine nine nine I
nine we got to get you a
mic 10 is I love all my children
so but I think Kurt Kurt's right though
it does it builds momentum you know and
and you know you only get to meet his
character at the end of the second
episode trust me there's a lot of Kurt
coming don't worry about it um but it
does I mean it really those episodes he
mentioned are all great but I think
there's something special in all of them
and that it does really it it at a
certain point it just it's on Rails to
the end and uh it was incredibly
exciting to get to the end of that
journey and and see how the season the
first season concluded I I I couldn't be
more proud of the work everybody did and
and particularly our cast was incredible
made us all look good yeah great cat
really good know these people they're so
great yeah Mari who who uh who in my
group Mari and Andre like you know you
have you had to um create a rapport with
with your with your fellow castmates in
in a in a way we were in these pods you
know it was like like the young youngly
pod and the older pod and and you know
not the a lot of the mistakes that
happen in these type of movies I think
are people go like oh the CGI will make
it and then they just like come to work
and just don't like show up or they they
they like you have an idea and you're
like well I'm not going to say it cuz
whatever I want to get into it but
but we're not that way and we all we it
was important to us that we you know
you're that you're in involved and
you're always in it you're always
pulling for the right thing because even
sometimes if it's the wrong thing at
least you were pulling for something you
know and I think that's an important
thing and and Mari Andre and I can speak
for my crew like they were so right
there with absolutely everything Mari
was so game like on the ropes where she
was getting beat up all the time the
ropes were like it's hard like doing
action is a legitimately difficult thing
that most people find out when they do
action you're like holy I got to
climb up this rope 17 times like my my
hands are going to fall off and and Mari
went like every time every take she was
like like gung-ho wanted to do
everything
Andre was like you so it was awesome I
mean that that was very nice to see
because it is not all the time that you
get your castmates who are as into it as
sometimes uh you are I got I had a great
group with u Kier Siana and Ren and uh
Ren is
uh Ren's a real he's very authentic he
he's he's just he's I don't know he's
he's he's Japanese James Dean man yeah
he's he's he's a very quiet guy but he's
really fun and he's always thinking and
he's I I think he's terrific I think
he's got a great future and his first
real professional acting gig he was his
Chef uh right before yeah one of his
auditions he was like yeah I only had
time to learn uh the one side I was I
was working last night we like oh what
were you what are you shooting what are
you filming and he was like no I'm a
line
cook progression of his character uh he
he he took the progression of his
character there some of the best stuff
in this but we yeah there's just there's
he and I both have a favorite in the
show um and it without you know it
doesn't wreck anything um I don't even
know the man's name he plays um Hoshi
Hoshi older
hosii yeah he's like great actor I mean
like really great Kurt I want to ask you
a question that has nothing to do with
Monarch um you have done so many amazing
things in your career there's going to
be people out there who have never seen
anything you done like kids whoever if
besides Monarch if they have never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
it would start with the Disney
[Laughter]
days the Kurt Russell collection
available on Blu-Ray now just in time
for holiday
shopping somebody once said uh his
career looks like it was handled by a
drunken
driver and I I I think that's really
well said cuz I was behind the wheel um
I don't know um what's fun about getting
older as an actor um if you've had the
opportunity to work with really um
really good directors and actors and
some and some ideas that at least you
loved uh because sometimes they they you
know you have to make a decision is this
something I'm going to do because I love
doing it I want to do it but it's
probably not really going to be loved by
that many people right now but I think
in 30 years I was always the 30-year guy
couldn't help it I just like I don't
really want to do that I want to do this
because I think that with that guy or
that girl we can make something that can
can be fun for somebody to watch at any
time in the future from now to then and
um in that regard the one thing that's
fun for me now is uh I hear all kinds
anywhere from Tombstone to the thing to
use cars to I forget whatever you know I
mean u i I was fortunate uh I don't know
I don't I don't know how to answer any
other way than that I was just fortunate
and I continue to be fortunate I
continue to be excited about it when you
get to work with people that are are
willing to dig
in uh it's no fun when they don't want
to dig in but when they do want to dig
in it's like that's yeah that's why I
join the circus man that that's that's
it and I just I I I just want to keep
doing it because it's fun I remember
probably you know stunted growth somehow
in that regard but I think we all are I
think all of us are to some that's in in
the Canadian Crews you know in in the
states it's base camp wherever the
trucks are and the camera stuff is and
the grips go it's base camp in Canada
it's the circus as because it really
feels like you're wrong and that's like
oh it should be at the circus that's so
much better right yeah I'm curious um
how much did you guys in the writing
process figure out like sort of a show
Bible in terms of uh figuring out all
the major moments between like 1945 and
2014 like all the things with Monarch
and trying to Fig like lay it all out so
in case you do three years or four years
you have it all figured out and how much
were you sort of like you know we're
just going to worry about this and we'll
fit it in later or you know we'll worry
about other things later I mean we take
it seriously I mean it's on top of the
the the kind of look I'm a comic book
guy I know it's like to care about this
stuff and you know when somebody's
faking it like I'm not faking it like
I'm going to be like wait a minute how
does that like I knew right going in
like I had a lot of this stuff in my
head just in his head but like but so no
it's a thing we take really seriously
and we work with our our partners at
legendary like we've the these movies
and everything's going to kind of dance
in weave but the kind of fascinating
thing is there's enough big raindrops
that there's big spaces between them and
it's okay to still have some question
marks because that's interesting for us
right you're going to see Monarch at
like the Pinnacle of its golden age when
Monarch was like NASA in the show when
it was like the coolest most Cutting
Edge science kind of place in the world
and they do this incredibly huge massive
thing and then chronologically in the
story the next time you see Monarch is
in Skull Island when John Goodman has
his hat in his hand and is begging for a
ride on a helicopter like that's a
spectacular fall right so part of the
our things like oh man how did that
happen you know we'll find out right uh
uh but it's it's part of the joy of this
is is there's a lot of questions and
it's writing is the answer yeah a lot of
it was established I mean we had this
the mythology the kind of canonical sand
box that we had was the legendary movies
was the the four now soon to be five
feature films that was the world that we
had been given to to work within and so
a lot of that was established there was
a history there are characters there's a
timeline there are there are Titans you
know that that there was a cannon that
we needed to you know uh be faithful to
but as Matt pointed out one of the great
things about working with legendary was
they gave us a lot of latitude to sort
of carve our own lane and make our own
show and there's a lot of space between
those movies I mean between uh Godzilla
in 2014 and king of the monsters is 2019
I want to say there's five years there's
five years where you don't know what's
going on in that world you know five
years of screen time right you meet
Monarch in 2014 and they're the
mysterious kind of xfy monster CIA thing
that nobody listens to and then 2019
they're like Civic civil defense the
sirens go off everyone knows go to the
Monarch bunkers look for the guys in the
Monarch hats they're they're testifying
before committee yeah right so like oh
that's fascinating how do they do that
how does this top secret Mega covert
underground thing then become the public
face of safety and responsibility that's
that's sort of you know where our show
lives one of the things that's cool
about this I that I like about science
fiction and
westerns science fiction Western you can
ask the big questions without looking
silly you can talk about where do we
come from is there a god is there
Justice you can talk about those things
without I don't know looking like a bad
TV show which I think there's a lot
of but when you do sci-fi and you have
the opportunity to explore these
things you have a great thing to take
advantage of it gives you it gives you
the chance to do something other genres
cannot do well they just can't they just
can't do it one of the things that I
find fascinating about watching the 10
shows is every once in a while you do
something and the timing of it
is is it it it it becomes relatable to
what you're living
through there are monsters in our world
and there are Monster people in our
world in our
show and in
both there are there are it you live it
you you can relate to it so when you do
really an interesting sci-fi that
happens to connect by
chance
to humanity and what's going going on
that's relatable to you that's what
makes sci-fi so exciting I think I think
that's what to a Sci-Fi fan they're
really feeling that's what they're
seeing that's what they're
understanding I think I think the thing
for instance is one of the greatest
sci-fi ideas there could ever possibly
be because you finally have to say I
mean they're actually beginning to say
some of it
now you know the concept of something
being able to imitate you so perfectly
that you don't even know yourself if
you're you well they're beginning to
look you know 30,000 years into the
permafrost and ask some
questions so with
Godzilla Mothra uh the Bramble what's it
called the Bramble bore uh you know the
you know ice arar or whatever
um who's to say we just haven't seen
them yet for those of us who haven't
seen them for those of us the guy in the
end this guy that have seen them well I
I just think that it's I think it's it's
Unique to sci-fi yeah well I mean
Godzilla has always stood in as for sort
of our worst existential fears it's like
what what what era of Godzilla is it the
postwar 50s is it the 60s is it into the
70s and there are certainly things that
he can represent that we can be afraid
of today post pandemic post P we were
shooting the show in the middle of a
global pandemic yeah yeah I mean he he
was God Zilla was born out of the Adam
the atomic bomb era um that was all
about us I love that about Godzilla I
think that's really
cool